thanks for being here uh in person or
for those of you remote or from people
in the future welcome folks from 20 like
32. it's good to see you
um
so i'm going to talk about uh this idea
of plastic dynamism and then a list of
my obsession with alliteration as you
see here
let me just first i figured i just set
the stage with some some numbers
just go through some data
3381
number of days since my last pcd seminar
it's always a pleasure to be here
three
number of previous pcb seminars it's
always been great to come down here i'm
very privileged to be able to be part of
this community
also three number of covered
vaccinations or thoughts i've had since
the last pcd seminar
37 number of different mass that i've
used lost i don't know just a lot of
things
one
number of times i've given the seminar
through a telepresence robot it's
actually one of the first times i did
this back in 2000 i believe
zero
number of in-person conferences that i
have attended in the last 24 months
who's with me on that yes right
67 that will be the number of important
things that i get to at the end of this
talk
and a hundred
my excitement as a percentage of how i
am to just be here with you and be part
of this really prestigious seminar so
thank you for having me
um
let's do some uh vocabulary so i put
this word out plastic dynamism and i'm
not sure how people reacted
maybe you thought of plastic
in a certain way
plastics
i don't want you to think about it in
terms of that material think about
plastic as
something that is malleable or something
that is elastic or
has plasticity and this actually comes
from this this terminology comes from
the futures who wrote about this concept
of
class of sort of plastic dynamism they
were talking about it at the turn of the
last century as
this idea of motion
and static and the tension between them
as you look at particular
processes materials or
artistic practices and they saw this
tension as something that was
quite interesting and compelling and i
want to draw that out as also this kind
of poetic contention they talked about
it is
between real and ideal forms between new
forms and traditional forms we've
discovered a form which is variable
evolutionary and quite different from
other concepts which have existed up to
now we've discovered
form in movement and the movement of
form only through this dual conception
of form can we give a hint
of plastic life in our work without
having extracted and removed it from its
living environment which would mean
arresting its motion so a lot about the
environment too now
i'll
give you another quote that uh was
inspirational recently
imagine something never done before
by a method never before used
whose outcome is unforeseen
and you might
hopefully find resonance with this as a
researcher as someone who has curiosity
about the world
you should probably be aligned with this
or thinking that's like how i want to
think about things what i found was i
came across this
as a quote from alan capro who was an
artist that really brought us things
like the happenings was really kind of
the genesis of questioning where the
line is between audience and participant
almost kind of set forth what we call
new media today and even some of the
concepts in hci about how we relate with
people interaction and environments
now i uh
have a group called the hybrid ecologies
lab at berkeley where we look at a large
spectrum of different kinds of
experiences
i'm going to try to tell a little
narrative about some of this work and
hopefully it will make sense and put
forth some new questions for for you
um but also it might uh might not
so hybrid let me just try to talk about
this and hybrid is really important for
me because
it's about this really
trans and cross-disciplinary kind of
approach and martial cohen says the
hybrid or the meaning of two media
is a moment of truth and revelation from
which new form is born that's really
important to think about those
intersection points and hopefully you'll
see them at little points throughout the
talk
ecologies
so i'm a computer scientist i'm an
artist i'm not you know an ecologist but
this idea of the scientific analysis and
study of interactions among organisms
and their environment such as the
interactions organisms have with each
other and with their abiotic environment
that's of interest so i'm very
curious about that kind of intersection
space
now
if this talk isn't for you this is the
only slide i ask you sort of maybe pay
attention then you can shoot tune out
but this is how we do our research at
large we basically will identify some
core metaphor to field
we recognize what that metaphor excludes
it could be a community an interaction a
technology a living organism whatever we
invert the metaphor to bring the
marginalized to the center
and then often we'll build alternative
embodiments study them in various ways
so
what i'd like to do just
go through a vignette
of sort of quickly moving through
some work that i've had the
you know great collaborations in the
past and try to position some of these
arguments
i'm going to give you
five little vignettes now
one
so a long time ago when i had a lot more
hair we worked with
at the time my advisor john canny at uc
berkeley and collaborated to build
telepresence robots and i'm not going to
tell you all about these robots you're
aware of many of them that you see now
there were flying blimps there were
different kinds of
ground-based robots that allowed you to
have a telepresence or an embodiment in
a remote space
obviously now this is a you know a
commercialized product you find them
everywhere you've probably driven some
of these but the genesis of this is
really early on uh at berkeley
and the the thing is when i think about
of course at that time we were thinking
about things like
what were the applications at the time
er
telepresence was really required
high-priced hardware it required trained
operators and the application was sort
of remote inspection and repair
and so those metaphors to invert them as
what if it was low-cost robotics no
training and the application was just
hanging out and that was kind of where
that went
but the inspiration also came from
artists so things like for example
uh
andy warhol silver clouds which are
moving
kind of floating
you can see almost blimp-like but very
much about this embodiment and the
spatial relationship
two
later on i was at intel research and
again collaborating with folks who were
largely looking at things such as the
object you see here which is a small
uh sort of sensor-based network they
were called moats sort of like dust
modes but the idea was
really looking at applications of
putting low-powered
routing algorithms for ad hoc networking
and different kinds of remote sensing
applications there's a lot of really
fundamental science that went around how
to construct these and operate them
but again my adjacency to that research
i saw something different in this device
and we thought about it as something you
could maybe wear
and the idea was could you have sensors
and communicate to people
using that kind of experience
so this is a slide deck from that time
the idea was you would
tap on this device
and a remote person would feel a kind of
remote sensation of vibrating
another experience that was possible was
that you could stroke it one way or the
other and the rope person would feel it
heating or cooling on the other end and
finally you could hold on it and it
would capture your pulse and transmit it
remotely to the other person
now when i did this
it was pointed out that quote this is a
stupid idea please don't do this
ever
you know how this turned out there's
other devices that we are now probably
wearing in this room
i didn't have anything to do with this
i'm not saying this wouldn't have
happened without me they might not even
be aware of this research
but i'm trying to point out that
sometimes you'll be doing work and i
want you to have the confidence to
really understand that you're doing
something that's often awkward but
you might be getting pushback but try to
stick with it that sometimes these
things pan out
now when i think about this of course
there's all these technical issues that
i'm going to kind of leave aside
it was thinking more about
the inspiration from artists again such
as john baldessari says
the best way to make art is to intrigue
and be a bit seductive you just say
here's this and this you figure it out
and what i try to get at is sometimes
you don't need to complete the narrative
for people you don't need to finish
every single thing with the interface or
the experience sometimes you do
you don't want incomplete interfaces for
an airplane pilot
but you might want to have people create
other narratives around messaging
three
around that same time we're also looking
at issues of citizen science as uh
manish mentioned in the introduction and
some of those were how can we think
about not just the mobile phone as a
communication device but as a super
computer radio station with sensors and
the idea was to attach different sensors
have the public sort of collect monitor
react and build kind of data sets around
this along with a bunch of remarkable
colleagues there's a huge body of work
easily you know maybe two dozen
different projects across that time
frame very different form factors
wearables street signs some of them
involved
looking specifically at how to design
more low-cost accurate particle sensing
looking at new form factors
looking at form factors that were in
sort of other objects these are some
children's toys that let them experience
different kinds of variations in soil
and water and air as they kind of
interacted and played
early on we started exploring how we
could get access to live data from the
environmental protection agency and back
in 2004 we created one of the first ways
you could access live
location-based data on your mobile phone
yes that's what mobile phones used to
look like for those of you watching in
the future okay
as you know now this is something that
just is there it's like about what 13 15
years later we just have this and that's
really empowering to see that transition
i remember doing the early studies
people didn't even know where to look
for air quality data
we also started attaching low-cost
sensors onto mobile devices this is uh
again at intel reacher research with rj
hanaki and others
and
we
um really pushed on this idea that these
sensors even though they were not as
accurate could play a role into a larger
data set
and now
you know 14 years later
the epa now uses low-cost air quality
sensors in its public product if you've
used it or looked at it the air now
and that's really empowering as well
also
we looked at how we could attach these
sensors to municipal vehicles
we worked with the city of san francisco
and collected air quality data and
explored it this is largely in
collaboration with allison woodruff and
polyoke and others at intel research
and then sometimes other universities do
the exact same thing
13 years later
the inspiration for this is as much
about the sort of science as it is about
thinking through rachel carson's comment
um
she wrote the silent spring and she says
the more clearly we can focus our
attention on the wonders and realities
of the universe
the less taste we shall have for its
destruction
and
i think
that kind of positioning about how to
get people to think about their world is
really powerful
four
energy we plug in we get power
i did a series of collaborations with
james pierce who is now faculty at uw
around thinking about energy as a
material we don't think about it that
way we think about it largely as
something we just get and it works and
we don't really give it much
consideration but what would happen if
we went in that direction
and i'll give you a thought experiment
so think of some loved one this is my
son many years ago imagine he's swinging
on a swing
some energy is collected during this
he brings us home
and then you read a book to perhaps the
light that
from that energy that he gave back to
you
and my question is is that different
than just plugging into the wall
and my claim is that it is it's
something that has it's emotional it's
gifted from someone it was there was
labor put in there was effort there was
a kind of aura about it that creates a
different experience than simply
you know just plugging into the wall and
of course when we talk about energy we
talk about reducing consumption and how
to that's a that's a very great strategy
but i would claim what about how we
might collect it or share it
or um you know keep it in different ways
and i'm fully aware that lots of little
bits of energy does not an energy crisis
solve but it creates some new dialogues
and some new inputs about where there
might be opportunities
we made these artifacts these sort of
energy mementos again you can think of
small little ways to collect and save
energy
imagine that you turned a hand crank
from your grandfather
and perhaps after he passed away would
you put that energy on a mantle is that
of value that's something that has some
something that is about him and his life
and some creative energy that he put
into it and there's many other examples
we also made these energy parasites that
we
kind of intentionally designed to be
from handcrafted material but they
actually captured energy in public
places so you can see
you could attach them to
a vehicle such as this headlight where
you could just sort of steal energy from
the headlight of a vehicle you could put
them in a water fountain where they
might collect energy on a handrail where
they could just sort of again siphon
energy from the handrail motion or on a
public transportation such as the tram
you saw
this is not free energy you're stealing
it but it's pointing out these
opportunities where there's places to
engage with energy
sort of siphoning or sharing
and that's when we kind of fast forward
what do we have now in our products we
have a way to share energy just the last
couple years most of our mobile devices
allow us to kind of swap energy and this
was a lot of the discussion at the time
and again people said i don't understand
this project it makes no sense why would
someone ever share energy and a very
short time later we do have these
products and now there's an idea of what
would that mean you kind of leave it on
the bus do you give it to friends and
all the kind of questions we were asking
again i would say
it's back to the aura as walter benjamin
talks about the authenticity of a thing
is the essence of all that is
transmissible from its beginning ranging
from its substance duration
to its testimony to the history which it
has experienced so everything that its
experience has this sort of aura to what
makes things unique
five
there was some work that i um was uh
really proud to do with elizabeth
goodman looking at familiar strangers
these are sort of real relationships
with people you have in public they're
strangers you don't actually
know them but it's a real relationship
where you sort of mutually agree to
ignore each other without implications
of hostility right so you ignore your
friend that means you're pissed off you
ignore your familiar stranger that's
part of the protocol
again at the time we were looking at
using technologies and bluetooth which
was at the time used for communication
we used it to figure out unique ids kind
of the same way you work with mac
addresses i know everyone in this room
and the audience is well aware of this
but it was quite unusual at the time
to think about that particular way of
operating
and this was visualizations on yes those
are more old mobile phones i get it but
this is how you did things
visualizing the kinds of familiar
strangers around you
now it influenced lots of different um
social media tools that are being
developed
and also in fact the way we do coveted
tracing now we didn't implement all the
kind of privacy protocols but it's the
exact same
mechanism so again this connection
of how this technology evolved
and again where did the story come from
at the time people were trying to be
about massive communication and sharing
things this was intentionally a standing
off from these kinds of relationships
and it was really influenced by
social psychologists such as stanley
milgram who looked at this phenomenon
back in the 70s
but is also influenced by artists so
folks like vito akanchi who actually
had this notion
of how you can actually do this
performance where you find a stranger in
public and you follow them until they go
into a non-public place i will not bail
you out of jail if you do this
performance but you're invited to do
this performance
but it got me thinking more about this
kind of intersection between
technologists
and where artists are operating
and one of the that came to mind
was some work from quite some time ago
by michael neymark and others the aspen
movie map so this was
for folks
this was on a laser video disc you can
google that to find out more what that
technology is
but essentially this was remarkable
on a screen you could map around and
move around
the sort of city of aspen colorado
now it looks remarkably like something
else that came about 30 years later
now i'm not saying if michael had never
done this project we would have never
gotten google street views that was
going to happen no matter what what i
will tell you is that michael received
an award
which is a golden fleece award which is
the sort of in congress called out as
the most egregious waste of taxpayer
money
okay so this
stop doing this at all costs this is
stupid
and there's something else
so sometimes things are just not
positioned the technology was even sort
of somewhat similar i got michael to
send me a picture of his rig
so there's a long history of these
and it's interesting to kind of reveal
them i would say another one might be
myron kruger
so another really
incredibly creative
sort of artist who was really in
computer science computer scientists
could not figure out really what he was
and where he fit in
but clearly he was looking at body
interactions things that we're very
comfortable with exploring today and
microsoft connect and sony
toy just beyond
and finally i'll offer up one that i
know we're familiar with twitter twitter
came out of an art project which was
really
during the democratic national
convention in 2004
a group created as their lightweight
texting tool to coordinate uh sort of
during the protests
the art group institute for applied
autonomy
when the pro when that was over they
went to san francisco
and a company that was dabbling in a
music kind of sharing tool
said hey why don't we try this thing
called we'll try to make twitter
and so that's the way that worked
so sometimes there's this back to this
hybrid this intersection i want you to
kind of think about that
and there's also a long history
in things like the experiments in art
and technology where we find artists
working with engineers so
jean tangley's homage to new york was
actually done with support from billy
cluver from bell labs who's billy cluver
well there he is
he worked with john cage and merce
cunningham and jasper johns and andy
warhol and others
and yes go bears sorry i got to pick a
plug for berkeley but he was a berkeley
alum and his faculty there for a while
cp snow wrote about this exact
phenomenon he said
the clashing point of two subjects two
disciplines two cultures of two galaxies
ought to produce creative chances
and we think well where else do we see
this
and i'm not going to go through some
exhaustive lists but i think probably
are locally here in the in the silicon
valley folks like steve jobs and steve
wozniak where you have a technologist
and
someone who's also a humanist kind of
coming together
um
i would also say there's there's a
broader range people like lillian
schwartz i don't know how many people
are familiar but
really pioneered a lot of early digital
animation she was very much a
technologist a member of the experiments
in art and technology and also a
technologist and artist
folks like madeline gannon more recently
who really understands the humanist side
of machines and robots but is also a
technologist in understanding them
and even someone like virgil abloh who i
got a chance to meet who is
unfortunately passed away last year but
came from a background as a civil
engineer
an architect went on to of course uh
found things like off-white and then ran
the louis vuitton
uh
you know menswear line really understood
where the culture of technology and
design
and art kind of intersected
so
hci talks are always required by law to
have a picture of mark weiser so here's
my picture
i don't need to introduce him to you but
let me tee up why i want to tell you
something about him you're well aware of
his history with ubiquitous computing
things such as bringing us the idea of
what the platforms would be for
computing
our tabs right so
we got our tabs in case you didn't get
that memo
pads i think you know where the pads are
the boards maybe a little okay hedging
our bets on the on the boards but i will
at least argue that that little table
there that him he and his colleagues
mocked up might look somewhat like your
table at your house or apartment little
you know little phones and things
sitting around
now he was asked to come and talk about
where this direction was going and
through the wayback machine you can
actually find his presentation from this
keynote at wist so well known in our
community
and they said mark tell us what is going
on you are the director of the computer
science lab at xerox park what do we do
is it resolution is it bitrate do we
need better screens is the networking
got too much latency
i said no no no
wrong he said
this is how you do it he talks about all
these fascinating things start from the
arts and humanities he's giving you all
this information this is the most
important part of the talk he talks
about issues of feminism
anthropology psychology again all this
interaction
so this is really
what's exciting about being at least a
computer scientist and thinking about
human computer action
and the kinds of challenges we have and
they're really broad right i mean
there's no way we're going to
instantly solve you know things around
the environment or education or the
economy
but hopefully these are the things that
design and some of the concepts design
let us speak to
now i'm going to take a little uh
pivot for a minute just because i want
to make sure that
i know you have some remarkable sort of
educational spaces here
but i do want to at least showcase some
of the new design thinking that happens
when you have these kinds of more
open platform interactive maker spaces
and so we have several of them this is
one of them that happens to be at
berkeley the invention lab it has lots
of people that move very quickly in it
but all of you probably hopefully had
the chance to experience
how to ideate in physical ways
with physical devices and lots of
different projects come out things from
looking at new kinds of prosthetics
people have done playful interactions
with headphones new kinds of
vibrators all kinds of cool directions
we've also thought about
why is the making happening in this
physical space we've let people check
out and take their kind of equipment
elsewhere to open conversations
and if you have
hopefully a chance to come to berkeley
you've also seen the jacobs institute
for design innovation this is one of our
2400 square for 24 000 square foot
buildings has a lot of kind of open
platform places to
give lectures be creative studio
classrooms
have conversations and one of the things
that's happened recently is the
launching of a new masters program so
for people that are here or listening
remotely please look that up and go to
design.berkeley.edu
this is my only plug of the talk but
please like check out the opportunity to
also have a conversation with us in a
studio-based residency design program
which is joint across
engineering and the college of
environmental design
now i also teach a class called critical
making we think about how people
will make and create
different kinds of experiences using
physical prototyping
it's part kind of a computer science
engineering class but it's also an art
class to critique culture and the kinds
of projects are pretty broad that come
out of this things like
interactive walls to talk about how
people might
talk about issues of
the border walls and false facts we
might deal with issues
of
how people
deal with depression and the feelings of
that there might be projects around
issues of air quality
there might be dystopian views of kind
of privacy and surveillance that allow
or prevent eye tracking and voice
recognition tools from working
there might be clothing that actually
pushes back on common algorithms for
people to actually
uh perceive different kind of facial
recognition
there might be illegal kinds of projects
that actually look for
uh meter-made carts going down and
dropping in coins and sort of
trying to thwart authority figures
there might be issues around personal
space
particularly around gender to push back
when people are too close to you with
your clothing to keep them
from crowding there might be projects
to kind of make you aware of locations
in an environment where sexual
harassment has happened
there might be projects that allow you
to push back when you're touched in a
way that's not appropriate by capturing
video and also kind of
visually cueing you this is not
appropriate
or clothing such as the toxic tie that
listens for misogynistic language and
then flips the tie in your face slapping
you so
a lot of different projects
but i want to talk about
a little bit about wearables a little
about some of the projects that i
mentioned that were in the kind of
beginning of the talk which is
what what does it mean to do wearables
and i think there's a lot of things that
people look at we always like to start
at artists
this is
tanaka's electric dress it's remarkable
to see this but i also want to think
about
also wearables and the body so artists
like stellark that have created body
modifications
things like rebecca horn who adds sort
of extra adornment to the body chris
burton who directly applies electrical
kind of interactions to the body and
yoko ono who questions the kind of
permissible engagement with the body
particularly around women
and i know i'm leaving out a lot of the
really exciting work that has been done
in hci and hopefully you'll you'll allow
me to kind of just have a discussion
around this artistic lens because i
think it'll lead to some interesting
directions
and that's partly because again i'm
going to bring mcloone and he says
artists show us how to ride with the
punch rather than taking a knockout on
the chin and i think that's important
way to think about
how artists help us navigate that
now sometimes we're looking what's going
on in the field what's at the frontier
but
i'm also curious
what people are hacking what are what is
the punk community doing and i certainly
don't condone this
but they're putting electronics under
their skin
they're doing things that i do not want
people doing
but
people get these kind of super powers of
having magnets out of their skins and
things
i want to think about
wearable or cosmetic computing
as this
open invitation to hopefully create a
new dialogue about what wearables can be
beyond just
pushing on traditional roles of
what we think of beauty or gender norms
and how it could open up a conversation
broadly about a more personal
performative
and meaningful expression of self
so what do we have now a lot of these
kind of things
and they're largely kind of flat screens
that we interact with
they um also you have to take them off
you have to charge them
and then there's the nightmare scenario
of like is my belt is is it the right
firmware to talk to my clothing that's
the right for the glasses like do i have
all the right things
and then what is our what is our
ultimate future
constantly things telling you what to do
and i'm not claiming we have sort of a
solution but i just want to put out some
other kind of uh points of conversation
and one of them was a project that we
did largely drawing from the google
jacquard team and with a number of other
colleagues thinking about how we can
look at
clothing and other materials that have a
woven fabric as an input but also in
this particular example as an
as a
output and that is these are not
emissive this is basically a kind of
thermal change that's in the dye
and it creates a very different kind of
aesthetic than
glowing lights or things like that and
it sort of points this idea that we
could change our clothing throughout the
day that what you put on
you know maybe this is how i look now
but after lunch maybe i lose these
stripes or maybe i have polka dots or
maybe something else happens i might
change the style
i might change the way that i appear
and we you might think well why would i
do that i kind of put on my clothes i
don't want to do that you do it anyway
you move a scarf around i might take off
my jacket
but similarly we already do that online
there's infinite number of skins and you
know emotes and all kinds of filters
that we apply we're constantly
manipulating our social appearance and
it makes sense we would do that through
clothing
so a couple other things one of them was
we thought how do we get around this
power issue one one project we explored
was thinking about using e-ink which is
a bi-stable material that doesn't
require power how could you take
images or things from the environment
and sort of put them onto your clothing
and they would remain remember it uses
simply the power from your phone
to actually have a wireless connection
and then send data across it
similar to how you do wireless
contactless payments now
and you could sort of change things and
we also looked at a number of different
clothing so you could have it in shoes
and you could have it in shirts you
could have it very overt or very passive
there's all kinds of different
experiences the main thing was it didn't
really require power and the interesting
thing is if you really did want to
you could just leave your phone in your
pocket and of course to receive power
you could have these kind of animations
so that was a fun thing to do
it also meant you could scale these
things so we looked at how it would
actually work as like a fingernail form
factor and how you might use your
fingernails as a place for
that data
those of you old enough
may or may not remember
uh this goofy movie total recall but
this was a scene from total recall
[Music]
so we could do almost things like that
that's somewhat close to where we could
be
now a couple more things on on the
wearable front here
one is
hair
i know i don't have hair i did used to
have hair that's how it goes i forgot to
bring my wig to really illustrate this
but
hair is also a really interesting uh
part of the body and we did a lot of
exploration of looking at what this
means and there's a lot of i'm going to
kind of move through it quickly but
certainly it's a personal choice but
it's a public experience
it signals a lot of individual identity
it also talks about a group identity
it's malleable think about the choice of
length or style or color there's lots of
ways you can configure it there's also
some shared ways that people touch and
there's an invited way of intimacy
around hair
there's also habits the way you touch
your hair actually is a lot of
non-verbal cueing and other kinds of
things
and
we thought how could we leverage that
and one of the things we did is
we looked at how we could embed a
technology that let you
sense what you were through capacitive
touch in your hair
and then we could create a color change
through a thermochromic kind of process
through heating
and then also we could create actual uh
physical change in the hair styling and
i'll just hint at this because i'm not
going to go into great detail but for
example you might get a notification
you know to meet someone well your hair
is going to respond
and then you'll kind of feel that and of
course how are you going to reply you
don't need to pull out your phone you
can just perform various gestures that
we can identify with your hair and that
will send the appropriate messaging
so similar there's ways that we can
actually
just decide either by your own
conditioning or others that your hair
style changes and we could have more
dramatic style hair changes there's a
bunch of different things that we can do
that i don't really go into all the
examples i'll just give you the more
big public scale version we can actually
get your hair to do quite dramatic
things there's no secret wires involved
this is kind of how it plays out
now this is by no means a kind of
wrapped up discussion of all the kind of
hair interactions you could have there's
a lot of things that
are brought across other cultures of how
hair and the meaning of hair and the
meaning of the signaling and there's a
lot of really great work you could still
do with hair
but at least
the balance of the kind of experience is
broad
and so the other thing i want to talk
about is skin and i mentioned this
stellar project these are works larger
ahead of john rogers lab really
inspirational way of putting kind of
sensors on the skin we looked at how you
could possibly do that
with low cost sort of
craft style
materials and the idea was to basically
use standard
silk screening to create temporary
tattoos that you could put on the body
and you could have all kinds of
different experiences from
you know capacitive sensing resistive
sensing strain gauges
so now you don't really need to interact
with your phone the sensing is right on
your body on your skin
and of course you want to play
games
the the point is that the skin can be an
interesting sight to investigate and
sort of send secret messages as well
we're also thinking about other kinds of
experiences on the skin and one of those
is clearly around haptics and how people
you know you get vibratory cues and
other kinds of ways of signaling
we went really small and got inspired by
some mems technology and you probably
won't even be able to see in this
picture but
there's a small
small tiny little almost millimeter
sized
actuator there that you can push on the
skin and feel and the idea was
what happens when you have
haptics experiences at that scale i'll
show you the best thing i could show you
sort of a video and this is at a very
very zoomed up in fact you're going to
see this disappear between the ridges of
someone's finger
print that's how small this is
so
what does this do this does not warn you
that you're about to like crash on your
you know bicycle or something it feels
like
very different experiences the user
studies that we've been doing have
really told us that this feels like some
like the air is brushing on the back of
your head or a small bug is crawling on
you or something's tickling you
and the main point is this opens up i
think a new vocabulary about what we
could do with haptics beyond just
vibratory cues and because of the scale
we see envisionments of how we can get
this down to small size
okay
i want to cover a couple more things i
know i'm going through a bunch of
projects but stick with me
i think you're aware of these maker
spaces
and a student of mine
run don tien did a lot of work on
looking at woodwork and wood joiner and
new kinds of smart tools
he also looked at new ways that you
could work with lays that you could kind
of have augmented experiences and you
could learn and feel a haptic feedback
as you use these either real or
augmented
but his last work
i wanted to share a little bit more
which is looking at kind of a
collaborative task where a robot
actually is kind of helping you in the
environment
i'm going to play you about one minute
of video with a droid users can borrow
precision and accuracy from an
industrial robot during open-ended
fabrication tasks
our system consists of the robot a
custom forced work sensor the desired
tool
and a projection augmented reality
display
here we show the readings from our force
torque sensor which are used to compute
motions for the robot
inspired by workshop jigs this system
can selectively constrain the user's
motions depending on the task through
software
to demonstrate a range of applications
we showcase four tools that can be used
with the droid
to use a hand drill with our system the
user selects that option through the
graphical user interface and mounts the
tool to the robot
after the drill is loaded the ar system
projects crosshairs onto the table to
show where the drill is pointing
when the drill nears one of the virtual
grids it will physically snap to the
grid like a haptic controller
when adjusting the orientation of the
drill the ar view visualizes the current
heading and elevation
for precise drilling the user presses
the latching button to constrain the
drill along the current axis of the
drill bit
[Music]
here the user is working with a
measurement probe so i'm not going to go
through all the examples but i think you
get the idea of this kind of way you're
working collaboratively with this robot
that has
better precision better kinds of other
material uh properties to help you with
the task record what's happening and
also build up
um kind of you can repeat the operation
because it can record what you're doing
so very cool work he's now at shaper
tools doing amazing things so i'm sure
you'll see
i asked him what he's doing there i said
what can you tell me goes well you know
what was in the sort of future work
section of my thesis i think that's
pretty much what we're doing so
for what that's worth um
so also the um
i want to talk about this idea of
materiality and unmaking i'm going to
talk about some unusual materials and
this is where a lot of my interests are
now and i've been working with one of my
graduate students catherine song
and we're thinking about unmaking and
this i'm going to kind of explain what
we mean by that we're drawing from some
early work again by an artist gustav
metzger who talked about auto
destructive art this is him talking
about it in the 1950s
gustav metzker founded the auto
destructive art movement that promoted
destruction as a critical but less
recognized form of artistic gesture
metzker created public auto-destructive
art with acid fire and machines to
foreground disintegration as a
first-class artistic
gesture numerous artists have explored
this theme such as young tangly's homage
to new york an elaborate kinetic
sculpture that gyrated and collapsed
destroying itself in the process
in shooting picture nikki desai fall
took aim quite literally at her
paintings obliterating them in the
process
more recently banksy's girl with balloon
underwent a destructive transformation
at auction
when upon sale it promptly destroyed
itself as onlookers stood by in shock
but our creative tools only emphasize
making for example today's
three-dimensional modeling software
offer us only limited atomic operations
such as extrude revolve sweep and loft
we argue for a radical expansion to this
vocabulary with a wide range of new
unmaking atomic operations
such as
crack
bulge
lean
[Music]
pit
so i'm going to explain
these are these operations in a new
vocabulary about how you can at design
time put in later
kind of in a time dimension when you
might want things to fall apart or crack
or beyond
and so katherine's going to explain how
that gets operationalized in an actual
process we'll now walk through an
unmaking workflow that we have developed
to operationalize splitting and bulging
and making can be implemented with a
variety of materials and fabrication
strategies
the strategy that we take as our example
is to 3d print a model using a
conventional plastic such as pla
and selectively design in hidden
chambers of an active material
here we use thermally expanding
microspheres or tems
upon heating these microspheres swell
like balloons
by modulating conditions such as heating
temperature and time tems hidden inside
pla objects create controllable unmaking
effects as they expand within
to enable the design of such objects we
created a software tool that is
integrated into standard cad modeling
software
users may interactively design and
visualize how they want their models to
split
or bulge
the tool automatically generates meshes
that can be exported to standard slicing
software and convert it into machine
g-code for 3d printing
tems come as a powder so before printing
we mix tems with water into a slurry
which we then load into a dual extruder
3d printer alongside standard pla
filament
the object directly after printing
appears to be an ordinary 3d printed
play piece
however when heated the object will
split or bulge as the designer specified
creating a unique artifact
this example workflow only scratches the
surface of what is possible with unmate
so the point i want to make is that you
could do it that example shows it using
these microspheres we can do it with
other materials and we can have it
happen when you
tilt an object or flip an object there's
other kinds of events that can trigger
this and the idea is to really think
about how that can open up a
conversation about
reusability reuse of materials and also
things that have this patina again this
aura that over time changes
so the final thing i want to talk about
oh uh oh is going to ask me a question
so i'm curious i know this is not your
orientation but
do you have some like
practical applications of this idea
other than art because i can only think
of like dystopian oh i now need to
subscribe to physical objects and then
some corporate entities said you didn't
have a fee so i destroyed it
i would say one it says that a designer
should think about a lifetime of their
product at the moment of design how it
might also come apart for reuse or
recycling you could also design
something that has one application and
then that falls apart it becomes
something else maybe
a cup to some i don't know different
kinds of things
yeah but you could design in multi-use
through physical transformation um
admittedly i'm giving the provocative
story
but there are uh it's one of these look
in the paper we obviously talk about
some other applications that kind of
address a bigger picture of how you
could think about having things
transform over time or have a uniqueness
to them that there's a lot of sameness
with digital fabrication
i don't know if that kind of addresses
it a little bit
okay
um all right last point i want to make
is this issue of this kind of hybrid
dynamism of how we can work with this is
a new thing that we've been working with
you could think of it as looking at
electronics but we want to put a really
heavy constraint around things that are
entirely entirely decomposable so you're
not going to see a super computer or a
fancy flat display but let's see what we
can do
so one of the projects that
katherine along with colleagues at
accenture have been we've been looking
at
is actually could you create a heating
element with leaves
so i'm going to have catherine explain
that in about a minute video here
so we take these
this powder that basically is applied to
the exterior of dried out leaves
this creates a kind of coating that we
can then more easily attach
[Music]
a silver nanowire solution again that is
a
biodegradable
we attach the leaves onto sort of paper
in the sense and then we use a
conductive pen again with a non-toxic
water-based
[Music]
material
and assemble that into essentially the
leaf becomes very much a resistive
heater
we use an inductive coil here it's just
a commercial one but you could actually
print that as well and when you actually
put that on a charger it creates
an over 70 degrees celsius heat change
so here's the delicious example
there are many others but the ideas you
can create in the sense this this cookie
becomes more soft and delicious now
that's the kind of quirky example what
it really means is you can create things
that
any kind of thermal condition so
pasteurization
things with
shape change which you saw in some of
the previous work there's a lot of
things we can do with heat
in that process and the idea is that we
could actually create
experiences that allow some
interactivity so in this sense the the
heating of materials are things inside
and the kind of heavy constraint is
still maintained meaning that we can
actually put this
into the ground at the end and it will
entirely decompose
in sort of just a
you know backyard so
we can just throw away what we have
everything in there is biodegradable
there's no materials that are
toxic in any way
and if you wait you know 30 60 days it
basically disappears
so yes we're relying on the power from
this inductive charge but we're also
able to do some things that are quite
remarkable
so la and the last thing i'll show you
and that work will be at kai this year
so you can see the full that's like a
teaser for that project
the last thing i'll show you is this
this may not look delicious but this is
almost entirely edible okay so you're
looking at
a completely
edible materials all sort of uh ethical
edible
and what is that exactly it's actually
in some sense a super capacitor we
basically looked at some material
properties to think about how we can
create
and use existing literature around
dielectrics and conductive material
there's
charcoal and egg whites and yes that's
cheese in there
and so you we can construct these
again
this is some leaf gold that is something
that's used in ornamental cake making
it's edible
and here it is powering an led i know
you can't really tell just trust me an
led does turn on from this particular
material
and the the point is this is sort of uh
more
ongoing work but the idea is can you
think about this heavy constraint of
things that can decompose you can eat
there could be things in the body what
can we do
with electronics can we have state can
we do a lot of things we like to do this
is really early thinking about it so
feedback welcome we're kind of playing
with this in the lab
and as promised these are the 67 things
you should know
ah we've been questioning which cheese
works best so yeah so you can your grant
money goes towards buying cheese this is
kind of questioned by the authorities
from the cheese board exactly we have
great resources in berkeley you can find
these online so i don't expect you to
read this uh the last thing i'll just
say is when you're doing your research
these are the kind of things i would say
one is make sure you use constraints and
you saw how we used this before
question progress sometimes you know
think about what's being lost to replace
those can be good things but sometimes
maybe you can bring them back
celebrate the new war so explore
unintended usages of things
or technology misuse the technology
hopefully you saw examples of how at
least we misused technology
be seamful when things don't work the
network doesn't work the heating
conditions aren't right that's also a
place to do interesting questioning and
finally
think about the assumed roles of the
technology and assume who should or
shouldn't be using them
and basically bend those try to push
back on those but do blend disparate
context
medium or disciplines or other things
be tactfully contrarian
you know when you have an alternate
viewpoint embrace problem making
sometimes your outcome might be more
questions that's okay
and read we've a lot of great things
you can read others
from all fields about what others have
been doing so again i know i didn't
really
give you a deep story at any of these
but hopefully there's some knowledge
about some scoping of work that is maybe
useful these are many of there's a short
list of really the many different
collaborators and institutions that have
supported the work and as i said before
it's just great to be here at stanford i
appreciate you all for being here and
the remote folks we see you wake up
wake up you
yeah okay great thank you all right
thank you again for having me here
[Applause]
so um we have time for maybe two
questions or so
yeah sorry if i didn't leave enough time
so maybe there'll be a question
oh sure
oh something remote it's coming in
standby
sorry about that um
very interesting framework um i was
wondering if you could comment on how to
see a uh kind of measurement and
evaluation of these kinds of outputs so
i guess where i'm coming from right i
work in international development and
kind of like unlocking resources
from
member governments and different kind of
regulators it's generally about some
kind of progress or effectiveness to
kind of make the case for these kinds of
efforts and uh i'd love to to hear
any any kind of thoughts or thought
processes and this is like i don't speak
for the world bank and in a way shape or
form okay thank you
okay yeah uh great so i think you're
saying because some of them i admit i
gave you a very high level view i didn't
talk to you about how we evaluate them
or make claims of success or our
functionality usability
we do often do that
where we'll look at a technology and
then we will obviously we do the things
that you might you know i just didn't
speak to them we'll bring people in
we'll give technologies to people we'll
evaluate their experience or what
applicability they have with it
sometimes they're a little challenging
so i think some of the early stories
that i told where at the time
some of those things seemed very awkward
and odd
but i tried to connect them to almost 10
or 20 years until they're kind of a
product or experience that people go
yeah that makes sense those are
sometimes harder
and people don't see
they can't connect the dots 20 years
into the future that's just a little
challenging for a lot of folks but
certainly anything that we do
we definitely are scientific about
analyzing it we're much more into the
qualitative experience
you could imagine
you know the
you know
sometimes there's a huge amount of labor
to find out if something's statistically
significant and for much of this work
it's just trying to get understanding of
what how it changes people's perspective
or invitation to a different kind of
material or user experience we're less
interested in can i prove beyond a doubt
that this
cheese capacitor is more desirable by 82
than another cheese capacitor i'm not
interested in that question at all i'm
interested in
what kinds of things do people start to
think about engage in
what new directions people want to go in
when they start thinking about the
constraint of something like you know
edible electronics where does that
conversation lead
so i don't know if that answers that i
think he dropped off the call but um
hopefully that was cool i'm here oh okay
thank you okay no no no i
of course i really like what you have to
say just make sure that so you should
think more about subjective perspectives
then be more malleable in these
measurement evaluation frameworks so
take a platform approach i mean
i don't know it's just very
i guess as a bureaucrat i think very
small so i apologize so
concretely would you say uh
take a more a broader view 20 years is
very hard for a regulator right
administrations are about four years old
right you execute a budget every year so
what does incremental progress look like
maybe that's a better question i
apologize yeah no i mean i know i think
i know what you're getting at and i
agree that many of these uh either
they're so far out or that it's just
harder but i would say
we for it it varies from project to
project so for example the one that
showed using this kind of robot to move
this drill around
we would like want to study like what is
the kind of
model for how that promotes uh new kinds
of experiences of making or creativity
in
a kind of maker space or how will tools
start to have more sensing and actuation
that they actually embody uh a way of
helping us be more precise or remember
things or there's many models that we
have of how we think uh just that
landscape of
creative tools and physical tools will
embed and embody different kinds of
technologies and other people have
looked at that too so
there'll be success of
how like what people can create with
those
how they think about their creative
process how does it constrain it or
allow them to scaffold into new skill
sets
so i briefly showed some woodworking
tools i don't know how to do woodworking
at all but using that tool i can
suddenly do
really amazing joinery work so now
that's a very empowering thing and so
we're very interested in these ideas of
uh kind of democracizing some of these
kinds of experiences and allowing more
to participate in that authorship or
that creative process so that's
sometimes how we measure success if
people that
are intimidated by some technology
or landscape how they can feel that they
are
also a kind of can
create things in that in that landscape
that's that's also success
so it's hard it varies from project to
project
and admittedly some of them are kind of
you know just a little out there so we
don't know yet but i think one of the
roles that i take pretty seriously is
i'm not
an entrepreneur trying to turn profit
for shareholders in the next couple
months i'm trying to think out
because of the
real essentially privilege of something
like tenure at a research university
that my role to society should be
pushing out questions that are really
not in the the right uh place for
someone in a startup it's too risky to
take people's money and try something
that far out
i can help try to
bridge that gap and create that kind of
channel so there's maybe some knowledge
when they move forward so apologies is a
very long answer but hopefully got
something across
well
i think we're out of time unfortunately
but thank you so much eric that was a
fantastic talk yep thank you come to
berkeley and visit i'm always around and
i'm close by i know how to get across
the bay so signal throw up a flag and
i'll come by and see everyone here
be healthy and safe and see you soon
thank you
[Applause]
you